Canadians have Tim Hortons Americans
have Dunkin Donuts and as a Canadian
coffee lover I thought it's high time to
put our American go-to Dunkin Donuts
coffee to the test
first the hot coffee
there's not much flavor there folks it
tastes a little like water like mild
water it's certainly not bitter it's
definitely drinkable if you just need
the caffeine fix and you're not really
into the flavor of coffee but if you are
she's not gonna satisfy let's try the
cold brew and I add a little sweet foam
on top because why not
that's much tastier but I think it's
because of the sweet foam again tastes a
little flat tastes a little watery not
my style and I think if you're used to
Tim's you're gonna be pretty
disappointed but if you've tried Tim
Hortons and Dunkin Donuts let me know in
the comments which you prefer